je m'appelle jeannick atchapa je suis
âgé de 50 ans je suis le maire de la
commune de bras-panon également de
nouveau conseiller départemental délégué
aux finances a fait général et habitat
quand on ouvre aussi se comprend la
ville de brax pas compte de la commune
de bras-panon celle de salazie également
et la partie sud de saint-andré elle se
ya un point commun voyagerez même mis à
deux points communs c'est là la rivalité
cette zone donc cédé comme une aventure
agricole et la partie sud de saint-andré
elle est également très agricole très
naturel et puis le point commun c'est
aussi l'arrivée du mas qui s'étend delà
de ça naze et jusqu'à le littoral donc
de saint-andré et de et de bras panon
c'est un canton qui me ressemble
parfaitement puisque je suis moi-même un
puits a produit 2 du canton donc très
attaché aux valeurs de
l'agriculture de l'eau comme vous le
savez sont des choses essentielles à la
vie et je souhaite à travers ce mandat
avec ma vie d'homme défendre cette
authenticité de notre territoire et en
faire un bassin de développement un
territoire d'avenir d'excellence autour
des jeunes des moins jeunes mais
également de l'emploi
au titre de l' équilibre des territoires
je crois que là ce doit être aujourd'hui
au centre des préoccupations du
département et notamment sur le
financement des communes déco l'utilité
donc à travers le pst le pacte social
territorial donc une importante à
travers cela de pouvoir aider les
collectivités là les communes à soutenir
le développement de la de la vie du
ménage ira donc là je parle de l'enfance
aux personnes âgées donc
l'accompagnement notamment sur l'habitat
on le sait aujourd'hui que c'est une
vérité pour l'ensemble des acteurs
politiques que la situation dans
laquelle se trouve la bêta à la réunion
est très compliqué il nous faut trouver
des solutions avec le président melchior
je pense que nous y arriverons et puis
il est question également de la
souveraineté alimentaire donc
l'agriculture et comment allait
accompagner la transformation de nos
terres agricoles en une tête qui nourrit
davantage sa population c'est pour moi
les enjeux prioritaires
pense que c'est une collectivité qui est
très proche de parts de ses compétences
des préoccupations des communes et de la
population le département pour avoir au
niveau de ses compétences aj delà de la
naissance jusqu'à
jusqu'à la mort auprès des populations
et donc
pour moi un acteur incontournable de
développement humain social mais
également
économique de notre territoire et je ne
peux que m'associer
en ma qualité de maire je crois que être
un bon représentant de ce capteur de la
population et pouvoir véhiculer
davantage autant que ce faire les
compétences du département sur le
territoire de la zone test notamment sur
le canton numéro 6